good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2309
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
in order to prevent unauthorized access
the area surrounding
scp-2309 has been enclosed by a
chain-link fence and given the public
designation of a proving ground used by
the georgian land forces a team of
observers is to be stationed at scp-2309
at all times to regularly report on the
structural condition of scp-2309
any breach in scp-2309 is to be reported
immediately and considered a potential
sk-class dominant shift scenario upon
receiving such a report foundation
military assets stationed in the middle
east are to be activated and deployed
according to contingency plan 2309 to
assess the situation and if applicable
engage any hostile forces that appear
description
scp-2309 is an approximately 20 meters
tall and 5 meters thick wall constructed
from blocks of iron covered in a thin
layer of brass standing between the
walls
pass in region georgia although scp-2309
is not susceptible to damage by
conventional means
scp-2309 continuously deteriorates
through an anomalous process in which
pieces of metal disappear from the
north-facing side of
scp-2309 leaving a variety of patterns
generally similar to claw marks in
appearance this process of deterioration
which occurs between sunrise and sunset
will continue until the thickness of the
wall is reduced to as little as five
centimeters in some sections between
each period of deterioration
scp-2309 will regenerate the lost
material at a rate of approximately 0.5
millimeters per second such that all of
the lost material will have been
regenerated before the next period of
deterioration
foundation historians believe that
scp-2300
was constructed during the 6th century
bce under the sponsorship of cyrus the
great founder of the achaemenid empire
the historical existence of
scp-2309 has been attested by various
written sources dating from as early as
the 1st century ce publicly accessible
versions of these sources have been
modified accordingly to obscure the
existence and location of scp-2309
of particular interest among these
sources is the following first-hand
account of
scp-2309 given by salaam at tergiamani
an official serving in the court of
caliph al-wathik of the abbasid dynasty
during the early 9th century ce
this is a report on the iron wall by
salam at terjemani department of
antiquities 1908 99-58
after the caliph reported a dream in
which he saw the iron wall of dulcanain
being breached by the yajuj and the
majjoj he dispatched me to investigate
this matter heading northwards to the
caucasus i arrived in tabalisi after six
months of travel there i made inquiries
concerning the state of the iron war and
found an old median who told me that he
had seen the iron wall and that it still
stood i then offered him 20 dinars to
lead me to the iron wall and without
comment he led me further northward to a
pass between the mountains
there i beheld the iron wall and to the
relief of both the caliph and myself i
found that the iron walls still stood
and that dulcanine's construction
equipment remained intact scattered
about the site
what i found strange however was that i
could see the scratches made by the
yaduji and the majut on the iron wall
but i could not see yajiro germajoj
themselves when i expressed my confusion
to the median he told me that the people
of the yajurden maju ju lie hidden
beyond the iron wall he then placed his
hand on my shoulder at which point i saw
the horde of yajiraj and majoraj
streaming towards us as they tore at the
iron wall they were as gruesome as i had
imagined for their nakedness was not
even hidden by skin and their hands
ended not in nails but vicious
surrendering claws
behind the horde of yajur janmajuj i saw
only devastation
every tree and plant had been uprooted
and the only beasts that survived their
onslaught were flies maggots and roaches
examining the disposition of the forces
of the yajuj and majuts more closely i
saw two masked men cloaked in red robes
like those of roman bishops presiding
over the horde from atop flesh-crafted
towers before them stood a massive
four-legged beast that was larger than
five elephants and had only a bony plate
for a face raising their staves towards
the air they guided the beast as a
performer might guide a puppet
responding to their every gesture the
beast began to charge toward the iron
wall trampling under foot the ajude and
the majoraj that strayed into its path
before its head slammed into the iron
wall
which emerged largely unscathed
i questioned the magee and as to why the
yaduji and majjuj continued this futile
effort to penetrate the iron war when
they could have undermined it or built a
scaffold he replied that where the yajuj
and majut stood the ground was harder
than damascus steel and the ceiling of
heaven was exactly at the height of the
iron wall so that even the most
insignificant insect could not fly over
it i told the median that i had seen
enough and he removed his hand from my
shoulder as yajud and majjuj disappeared
from my sight he told me that the caliph
and the rulers of every civilized land
must heed the threat of yajuj and majjoj
sometimes i question whether my vision
was a sign from allah or a majin trick
but i am inclined to believe that i was
not deceived for allah is knowing and
seeing and i saw only what had already
been revealed
foundation archaeologists began
evacuations of the area surrounding
scp-2309
in 1992 among the articles of interest
discovered were as follows
a cache of approximately 1 000 lydian
coins
a large number of iron and bronze
fragments from achaemenid weapons and
armor
a collection of gears and other machine
parts probably used in the construction
of scp-2309
many are stamped with the seals of the
mechanite temple cults of the ionian
city-states
a mass grave containing skeletons with
humanoid body structures largely similar
to those of baseline homo sapiens
sapiens deviating from the baseline in
that their skulls largely consist of a
vertically aligned pair of sharp jaws
and that their fingers end with bony
claws these specimens have been noted to
resemble captured instances of sk bio
type b
and finally a large clay cylinder
containing the following record
written in old persian of the
construction of scp-2309
and the circumstances in which it took
place
this is iron wall cylinder by unknown
author department of antiquities 1994 23
87.
all civilized men pray cyrus beloved of
ahura mazda king of kings king of persia
babylon sumer
and lydia his army which counts in its
ranks as many men as there are drops of
water in the tigris and the euphrates
marched into the caucasus to confront
the invaders who have sailed out from
attitum led by karaski yagaha and
karaski magaha david generals of the
angra menu they have caused great
mischief in our lands at first cyrus's
army drove them back to the pass but the
onslaught was endless such that even the
companions could not hold them back in
his divinely granted wisdom cyrus
resolved to build a barrier to hold back
the davis and their accursed armies
gathering the wisest men from all
corners of his empire cyrus journeyed to
ionia where he enlisted the mechanite
builder priests as cyrus's armies held
the line the mega knights erected a
great wall from blocks of iron and
poured over it a layer of consecrated
brass so that kasky yagaha and karski
magaha and their armies will be sealed
away from mankind in the realm of drooch
until the end of time
because of the eschatological
significance assigned to scp-2309
and the existence of written and
archaeological evidence suggesting that
scp-2309 was constructed as a barrier
against sarkic armies it is believed
that the breach of scp-2309
if and when it should take place
may constitute an sk-class dominance
shift scenario historical and esoteric
research regarding the nature of the
threat posed by scp-2309
and possible improvements to its
containment is ongoing
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to aletreon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
your local fishman
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
octo potato football match hms lily
the almighty fish
syodio dimnatus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you